obstruction is very quickly becoming the
name of the game because Donald Trump is
now officially refusing to cooperate
with the houses impeachment inquiry we
will talk about what this means we will
talk about what will happen next which
is really the most important question I
told you before that there are just too
many differences between Bill Clinton's
impeachment and Donald Trump's
impeachment to really draw relevant
parallels in terms of the course that
they might take the outcome that they
might have Bill Clinton's impeachment
was over lying about an affair Donald
Trump's is over
borderline treasonous behavior Clinton
wasn't tweeting all day about it Donald
Trump is Clinton didn't have something
equivalent to Fox News and right-wing
radio and the social media echo chambers
that Donald Trump has Clinton cooperated
with the inquiry while Trump was always
likely not to and now we know that he
will not the White House said yesterday
it will not cooperate with this
impeachment inquiry period they said
this in a letter of eight or nine pages
of length where he calls the entire
thing unconstitutional despite of course
impeachment being enshrined in the
founding documents of the United States
of America the letter is filled with
complete non arguments about why he will
not be participating and this is now
going to set up a major battle with
Democrats in the house this is like
telling the police no you are not
allowed to investigate me I don't
participate and I think you
investigating my possible crimes is
harassment at the highest level if you
did that the police through the courts
would enforce their right to investigate
and the question now is will the house
enforce its right to investigate but
it's actually more simply will they will
the subpoenas even start
if the subpoenas start will the
subpoenas be enforced because you can
subpoena anybody you want and a court
can even say you must abide by the
subpoena mr. Trump mr. Trump's lawyer
whoever but what if you
ignore that court decision what if you
ignore that courts decree so far there
have been no consequences to Donald
Trump or others that he's directed to
ignore requests and subpoenas and unless
that changes Trump's going to get away
with this this is actually you know we
were told about there could be a
constitutional crisis this is actually a
constitutional crisis you need to
understand that it's not a hypothetical
one it is one right now there is no
legal basis for Donald Trump's position
that a co-equal branch of government
using its investigative power is
unconstitutional there is no legal basis
for ignoring requests from such a
constitutional inquiry you can make the
argument that Trump not cooperating in
and of itself is actually an impeachable
Act you could make the argument that the
specifics of the Ukraine Fiasco that are
being adjudicated presumably by the
impeachment inquiry becomes secondary to
what is clearly the impeachable action
of not cooperating with a legal
constitutional inquiry conducted by the
power vested in a co-equal branch of
government and do you know why Trump and
his lawyers are doing this I mean you
need only look at the last two and a
half years it's worked so far
they suspect and they're not crazy to
suspect it that based on how things have
gone the last two years that ultimately
they will not be forced to participate
or to face consequences rather if they
are told to participate but decide not
to anyway so why not try this
my senses and in reading a lot of legal
opinion about this over the last couple
of days my sense is that even if Trump
doesn't get the gravity of the situation
that he's facing here that his attorneys
do get it and so they have made a
strategic decision that hey just not
going along with this stuff has served
us pretty well we got Trump out of
having to meet with Moeller in person
and instead he answered questions in
writing bogus answers I mean deceptive
answers incomplete answers answers that
by any normal assessment we would say
are
truths in many ways and he got away with
it so this is obviously the right
decision that one would make if so far
they've gotten away with just not
participating getting in the way not
doing the thing so we've got a
constitutional crisis here we will soon
see whether it will be resolved in
accordance with the Constitution and we
will I mean listen the most important
thing at this point is going to be are
Democrats going to get it together and
do everything that they can to force
compliance with this investigation Trump
may still ignore it Trump may still not
participate but Democrats need to start
using their subpoena power they need to
start looking at holding people in
contempt there is a mechanism for doing
this we've not even really discussed it
because it seems so room the idea is so
remote to me that we would actually see
contempt people held in contempt by
their refusal to participate but this is
the conversation we're having it is a
constitutional crisis right now not at
some point in the future let me know on
Twitter or in the YouTube comments
please tell me what you think the end
result will be of Donald Trump saying we
are simply not going to participate